Chamanes, magos, brujos y hechiceros.
Buena parte de América Latina es una tierra
de viejas supersticiones, una tierra de celebración
de rituales donde el sentido mágico de la
vida florece en todo su esplendor.
Amigos, gracias a todo este despliegue de
fantasía y magia… fue precisamente aquí,
en América Latina donde a lo largo del siglo
XX más se desarrolló el “realismo mágico”,
una corriente artística donde los mitos,
las leyendas, la magia y la fantasía se fusionan
y se integran con la realidad…
Pero… un momento… vamos a ver, puede que
alguno de vosotros se esté preguntado…
¿Eyn? ¿Me habré equivocado de canal? ¿Por
qué diantres me hablan en VisualPolitik del
sentido mágico de la vida?
Pues…. Porque todo esto,… no es algo que
afecte solo a la cultura…
En Latinoamérica, este sentido mágico de
la vida tiene mucha influencia sobre muchos
elementos de la sociedad…. Incluyendo la
política. Atentos.
(EL REALISMO MÁGICO EN LA POLÍTICA)
Amigos… A lo largo de la historia, en muchos
países, incluidos los países europeos, ha
sido relativamente habitual que los caciques,
los tiranos o los monarcas absolutos trataran
de legitimar su poder de la mano de la religión.
[Bueno… aunque ahora que lo pienso, la verdad
es que esto no es tan antiguo ni desde luego
una, cosa del pasado, al fin y al cabo es
más o menos lo que está haciendo Vladimir
Putin en Rusia con la Iglesia Ortodoxa]
El caso, amigos es que todo esto es algo muy
parecido a lo que han hecho - y hacen - algunos
caudillos latinoamericanos…
En este caso utilizando no solo la religión,
sino también las tradiciones, las supersticiones
y las creencias populares, ¿para qué? Pues
para legitimarse en el poder o reforzar un
discurso populista.
[Claro, vamos a ver, si una forma de hacer
política no funciona pues algo se tendrán
que sacar de la manga, ¿no?]
En algunos ocasiones todo esto ha supuesto
construir realidades que están a medio camino
entre la verdad y la fantasía o incluso revestir
al líder con poderes sobrenaturales.
Claro que… todo esto no suele ser más que
un hechizo… un hechizo cuya finalidad en
la mayoría de los casos pasa por consolidar
el poder de algún que otro tirano.
Al fin y al cabo, ya sabes, la magia da seguridad…
Explica lo que no se entiende racionalmente
y arregla lo que de otra manera no se consigue.
Pero… un momento, ¿Queréis algunos ejemplo?
Pues… ahí tenemos el caso de Francois Duvalier,
un dictador que durante 14 gobernó Haití
a través de la violencia y el Vudú.
Sí, sí… con el vudú.
(Francois Duvalier fue un salvaje tirano que
se autocalificó como un Houngan, es decir,
como un Sacerdote Vudú, que hacía rituales
de lo más extraños y que trataba de imitar
al Barón Samedi, ni más ni menos que el
señor de los cementerios en la tradición
vudú, para tratar de hacerse pasar por una
encarnación de él.
Así es, de repente el tirano se convirtió
en el “señor de la muerte”.
Duvalier creó su propia milicia conocida
como los Tonton Macoute -el nombre de un ogro
del folclore haitiano, algo así como el hombre
del saco- reclutando -generalmente en las
cárceles- a unos perfiles muy adecuados para
su propósito de servir al señor de la muerte:
asesinos, ladrones y todo tipo de delincuentes
que se dedicaron salvajemente a mantener a
raya a la población del país.)
[Qué mejor forma de mantener las cosas bajo
control, ¿no os parece?]
Otro ejemplo, tal vez un poco menos folclórico
pero no menos intenso sea el de Venezuela…
Por un lado tras la muerte de Hugo Chávez,
desde el régimen se trató de conferirle,
de darle, una cierta categoría de divinidad.
Para ello, se llegaron a montar altares e
incluso se modificó el Padre Nuestro - la
oración católica por excelencia - por el
Chávez nuestro que estás en los cielos.
Fijaos.
Y luego también estuvo la historia del pajarito….
Pero no solo eso, por otro lado como muestra
de toda esta fusión de realidad y fantasía…
tenemos también la instrumentalización de
Simón Bolívar o la narración de la guerra
económica.
[Algo así como... el resto del mundo tiene
a Venezuela en la diana y quiere su destrucción,
pero no nos rendiremos].
Cómo ya os hemos contado en VisualPolitik,
en un montón de videos, los problemas que
tiene Venezuela se deben básicamente a las
políticas de la “revolución bolivariana”.
Pero… continuemos.
(Otro caso lo encontramos en Nicaragua…
por ejemplo, en Rosario Murillo, Vicepresidente,
Primera Dama y compañera inseparable de Daniel
Ortega.
Con las manos repletas de piedras turquesas
para espantar la mala suerte, sus discursos
son una especie de cocktail entre espiritualidad,
religiosidad y política. )
Y, desde luego, no es nada extraño escuchar
en sus discursos términos como bendición,
prodigio,milagros... o arengas como ¡Nicaragua
cristiana, socialista y solidaria”!…
Todo, claro, con el objetivo de levantar el
fervor popular y mostrar algo así como una
realidad dopada donde las políticas del régimen
de repente adquieren una enorme trascendencia.
Pero… no lo digo yo, atentos.
(“La vida es una comedia. La política,
en el mundo, se ha convertido en un circo.
Apuntémonos a ser los magos del circo”.
Rosario Murillo)
¿Os habéis dado cuenta?
Al final no es más que una forma de hacer
populismo para mantener el poder y también
para llenarse los bolsillos… pero, oye,
que narraciones más apasionantes, ¿no os
aparece? Lastima que luego la realidad sea
muy diferente.
Amigos, echemos un vistazo, precisamente,
a la realidad de lo que Rosario Murillo califica
de Patria bendita, católica, socialista y
solidaria…. Atentos.
(EL HECHIZO)
Nicaragua, un país que parece condenado a
sufrir dictadura tras dictadura, vive una
enorme crisis política.
La represión del gobierno contra las protestas
cívicas que reclaman más democracia y libertad,
se han saldado con la pérdida de más de
300 vidas.
Os hemos hablado ya de ello, aquí en VisualPolitik
desde donde enérgicamente hemos condenado
la violencia ejercida por el régimen de Daniel
Ortega.
Claro… que Rosario Murillo no lo ve de la
misma forma.
Según ella lo que ocurre en Nicaragua es
que la Patria bendita sufre una invasión
de espíritus malignos… [que ojo, no son
los que ejercen la violencia o meten mano
en las arcas públicas… sino los que buscar
acabar con el desmedido poder de ella y de
su marido, claro.]
Y, ojo, amigos, porque la señora Murillo
sabe muy bien de lo que habla. La otra vida
y el maligno no son secretos para ella.
Desde que la familia Ortega-Murillo retornó
al poder en el año 2007, cada 5 años, cuando
se celebran elecciones, todas las sospechas
apuntan a que miles de personas fallecidas
salen de sus tumbas y se encaminan a votar…
por supuesto, por Daniel Ortega.
[Ya sabéis, un clásico en el fraude electoral.]
Y, ojo, porque en Nicaragua, los muertos no
solo votan, en algunos casos también se presentan
a las elecciones.
Sí, sí, tal cual como lo escucháis.
("Nicaragua, el país donde los muertos pueden
ser electos. Investigaciones denuncian listas
de candidatos electorales "preñadas" con
nombres de difuntos. El País)
Por cierto, ¿Sabéis que respondió el Consejo
Supremo Electoral, supuestamente el órgano
responsable de velar por el buen funcionamiento
de las elecciones, cuando hubo quejas por
todas estas “apariciones”? Atentos.
(“Investigar si son ciertos o no son ciertos
(los candidatos), si existen o no existen,
si están vivos o no están vivos, si están
en el cielo o en la tierra, no es facultad
legal del CSE” Consejo Supremo Electoral)
[Vamos, fraude, fraude, fraude]
Pero ahora bien… si en Nicaragua las personas
que ya no están en este mundo pueden votar
y presentarse a las elecciones… ¿por que
no pueden trabajar? A ver, ¿Por qué?
Pues eso es, precisamente, lo que debió preguntarse
Daniel Ortega cuando en 2016 falleció, René
Núñez, el presidente de la Asamble Nacional
- el Congreso de Nicaragua.
Según la ley - y el sentido común - el presidente
fallecido debería haber sido sustituido por
uno nuevo… sin embargo, no, nada de eso,
el plenario, formado básicamente por diputados
afines al gobierno, decidió mantenerle en
el puesto una temporada más.
("Un muerto preside el Parlamento de Nicaragua.
René Núñez, leal operador del presidente
Daniel Ortega y fallecido el 10 de septiembre,
es nombrado presidente de la Asamblea Nacional.
El País. (09/2016))
[Vamos que en Nicaragua, los muertos además
de votar y presentar a las elecciones también
aprueban leyes…….. Qué macabro, ¿no?]
Ahora bien, puede que alguno de vosotros se
esté preguntando… ¿Pero… Enrique, que
saca la Familia Ortega-Murillo con todas estas
“cacicadas”?
Seguro que la inmensa mayoría ya os lo imagináis,
pero por si acaso, hagamos un repaso a esta
particular familia que ha convertido a Nicaragua
en su cortijo particular.
(DEJANDO A UN LADO LA FICCIÓN)
Amigos, Nicaragua es uno de los países más
pobres de América Latina, la renta per cápita
apenas supera los 2.000 dólares anuales y
la pobreza afecta a casi 1 de cada 3 personas.
Por supuesto la situación de la familia Ortega-Murillo
es muy diferente… claro que en esta ocasión
no me voy a referir a su patrimonio… sino
a cómo utilizan el presupuesto público…
a su antojo.
Empecemos por ejemplo, con Laureano Ortega,
uno de los hijos del presidente, de Daniel
Ortega. El bueno de Laureano trabaja para
el gobierno, como asesor de la agencia de
promoción de inversiones Pro Nicaragua y
es conocido por ser un gran coleccionista
de relojes Rolex. [Ya sabéis, Nicaragua Católica,
Socialista y Solidaria]
(Pero… no solo esto, Laureano es un tipo
con gusto así que con fondos del gobiernos,
del gobierno de uno de los países más pobres
de Latinoamérica, se ha montado su propio
festival de Opera - cuestión de prioridades
- que por supuesto le cuesta un buen pico
a todos los nicaragüenses.)
Luego tenemos a Camila Ortega, una joven que
quería ser modelo. Como no lo consiguió
¿qué pensáis que hizo? Pues sí, le pidió
dinero a papá para montar “Nicaragua diseña”,
un evento al estilo de la New York Fashion
Week. Todo con dinero público… en un país
donde 1 de cada 3 personas vive con menos
de 3$ al día.
Pero claro… ¡Qué lujo ver a diseñadores
y modelos internacionales realizando pasarelas
y cócteles en los mejores hoteles y centros
de convenciones del país! [Nicaragua Católica,
Socialista y Solidaria]
Ahora bien, ¿de qué sirven las pasarelas
y los festivales de Ópera si no son convenientemente
promocionados por los medios de comunicación?
Pues… no os preocupéis, no hay ningún
problema, el señor Ortega tiene a sus otros
hijos liderando 5 canales de televisión y
múltiples radios… todas claro favorecidas
por el gobierno… [ya sabéis hay que impulsar
la industria audiovisual].
(Pues bien, entre estos otros hijos metidos
a magnates de los medios de comunicación
está el bueno de Juan Carlos, un tipo que
además de dirigir la agencia que se encarga
de la publicidad del gobierno, también aspira
a dar el salto al mundo del cine.
De hecho, entre sus proyectos estuvo la producción
de una película, una especie de comedia para
adultos - con algún rombo y bastante mal
gusto - que el gobierno de Nicaragua decidió
financiar con más de 400.000 dólares.)
Lastima… que la película no tuvo el éxito
esperado y apenas logró recaudar 3.000 dólares
¡Pobre Juan Carlos!
Y ya por último tenemos a… Rosario Murillo…
ya sabéis, la de [Nicaragua católica, socialista
y solidaria]
(Pues bien, el caso es que Rosario decidió
gastarse… bueno mejor dicho, gastar del
presupuesto público, en este caso de la empresa
pública de electricidad, varios millones
de dólares en decenas y decenas de enormes
árboles de metal que además cuestan una
pasta en mantenimiento... los árboles de
la vida… imprescindibles, prioritarios para
el desarrollo del país.)
Festivales de Ópera, pasarelas de moda, películas,
empresas de medios, los Árboles de la Vida…
caprichos todos ellos pagados con dinero de
todos los nicaragüenses.
Y luego ya aparte, por supuesto, todas las
sospechas de corrupción y malversación de
fondos públicos…
Amigos, esta es la realidad, esto es lo que
se esconde tras la ficción construida por
políticos que tratan de legitimar con fantasías
lo que no pueden hacer con resultados.
Así es como muchos caudillos, como Daniel
Ortega, han convertido a sus países en auténticas
haciendas privadas para su propio beneficio.
Pero, ahora la pregunta que podemos hacernos
es, ¿Podrán los nicaragüenses romper el
hechizo del sandinismo?¿Conseguirán librarse
de este corrupto, violento y represivo régimen?
Déjame la respuesta en los comentarios y
también en esta encuesta.
Si el vídeo te ha resultado interesante dale
a like y no olvides suscribirte a VisualPolitik.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.